nouvelle nuit et nouveaux bombardements
dans la bande de gaza aucun signe
d'accalmie ne semble apparaître alors
que le conflit entre israël et le hamas
entre dans sa deuxième semaine pour le
premier ministre israélien benyamin
nétanyahou les frappes aériennes dans le
micro territoire ne sont pas près de
cesser la directive est de continuer à
bombarder les cibles terroristes l'armée
le fait très bien
aujourd'hui elle a visé un commandant
supérieur du jihad islamique
nous avons frappé l'unité navale du
hamas et nous continuons à bombarder des
cibles souterraines le métro du hamas et
d'autres cibles
nous continuerons à prendre toutes les
mesures nécessaires pour rétablir le
calme et la sécurité pour tous les
résidents d'israël font une rhétorique
belliqueuse également reprise par le
hamas qui a envoyé plusieurs dizaines de
roquettes
hier sur le territoire israélien une
partie de ping pong armée dont les
populations civiles pâtissent avec plus
de 200 morts et des milliers de blessés
en majorité palestinienne
face à ce drame et pour la quatrième
fois depuis la reprise des hostilités
le conseil de sécurité doit se réunir en
urgence aujourd'hui mais l'onu semble
restée impuissante et en reste aux
déclarations d'intention
nous continuons à pousser activement
toutes les parties vers une cessation
immédiate des tirs entre israéliens et
palestiniens
notre coordinateur spécial torvalds
landes travaillent sans relâche avec
toutes les parties pour rétablir le
calme
une impuissance international symbolisée
par le refus américain à l'adoption
d'une déclaration du conseil de sécurité
appelant une cessation des violences
si joe biden sous la pression de son
camp a appelé un cessez le feu hier soir
washington ne devrait pas changer sa
ligne de conduite dans les prochaines
heures
de notre point de vue nous nous
concentrons sur chaque action que nous
entreprenons chaque déclaration que nous
faisons dans lé but de réduire la
violence et de mettre fin aux
fier sur le terrain il ya des moments
dans la diplomatie nous devons garder
ces conversations discrètes un manque
d'unité international symbolisée par la
multiplication des initiatives lancées
pour tenter de résoudre le conflit
dernière en date celle d' emmanuel
macron et du président égyptien abdel
fattah al-sisi reçu lundi à l'elysée une
véritable cacophonie diplomatiques alors
que les tensions ne devrait pas
redescendre sur place
le fatah parti du président de
l'autorité palestinienne mahmoud abbas a
ainsi appelé aujourd'hui à une journée
de la colère et de grève générale
[Musique]